in this video i explain the
spread dimensions standard deviation
variance range and council distance and show
you how you can calculate these parameters online in a few
steps
spread dimensions are part of the
descriptive statistics the most
commonly used control dimensions are the
standard deviation which is the
average distance of all
measured  Values ​​from the mean
value indicate the range, which is the distance
between the lowest and the
highest value of a distribution, and
the quantity distance, which represents the
spectrum in which the middle 50%
expression
lies  we about the
standard deviation the standard deviation indicates the spread of
a variable around the mean
value there we have it the standard deviation is
the average distance of all
measured values ​​of a variable from the mean value of
the distribution hence the
standard deviation gi  bt to how much
all values ​​scatter on average
let's take a look at this
example where we look at the body size of people
first of all the mean
value has to be calculated now of course every
person has a deviation from the mean let's
say this person at 30
centimeters  from the mean value this
person by 8 cm
this person by 12 cm and this person
by six centimeters and so on and
so forth so every person has a certain
deviation from the mean value
now it could be interesting to know
how big the deviation of all people
is  we want to
know how much the whole person
deviates from the mean on average
this gives us the standard deviation
for calculating the standard deviation
there are two slightly different
equations
on the one hand you can use
the entire
population to calculate the standard deviation on the other hand
this can also be calculated if you
a sample  e is
available all values ​​of
the total population are available if you use this formula
to calculate the standard
billing, however, we only have a random sample will use this formula the main difference is that here once a - stands up and here we only have
the arising
otherwise both formulas are complete
identical to the standard deviation if
you take the population as a whole it is
also abbreviated to sigma if we calculate the
standard deviation based on a
random sample this is written
with smaller
now of course it is still interesting to
know what the difference is between the
variance and the standard deviation
the difference between the care
parameters  variance and the
standard deviation is that the
standard deviation measures the average
distance from the mean and the
variance is the quartered average
distance from the mean in other
words the variance is the qualified
standard deviation and d  he
standard deviation is the root of the
variant let's just look at
the two forms here
on the one hand we have the
variance on the other hand we have
the standard deviation then
we can see that both forms are completely
identical except for the
standard deviation again  the root is taken
,
which is not done at allianz
when you report results
, the standard deviation is usually always
used because the
standard deviation has the same
unit as the original variable
if we go back to the example of
politics measuring height, we say
we have it  height measured in
centimeters and it came
out that the mean value is 180
centimeters now we
can calculate the standard deviation and it
could come out that the
standard deviation is 15 centimeters now
we know that the people on average would deviate
from the mean value by 15 centimeters
wi  r to report the result with
the variance, you would have to
take the square root yourself so that you
can classify the result better, so and
with that we come to the range of the
scatter smart range gives the
difference between the highest and the
lowest value in a random sample
if we look at that again  looking at our
example, we
simply listed the height of several people again
and we have
a minimum value here we have a
maximum value and the range is
accordingly simply the
difference between the maximum value and
the minimum value so we now come to the
last control parameter
and  inter quarterly interval in contrast
to the range in which 100 percent of all
values ​​lie, one often wants to
know the area in which the middle 50
percent of all values ​​lie. This
spread spa meter is called inter
quarterly
interval
values ​​not taken into account when we
look at height and we
sort the people in a row
then we cut away the bottom 25
percent and the top 25 percent
and then just take the remaining 50
percent of the person
from that 50 percent we calculate
the smallest  and the greatest value
is then the intercontinental distance and
now i would like to show you how the
scatter measurements could be easily
calculated online here for google tier
please go to the data tab or simply
enter fitter type t in our browser once
you have done this you click  just
click statistics is enough in this table
you can now copy your own data
before you have to look at the
empty table
i will now just use the
example data that is entered
before we want to calculate the scatter parameters
let's just stay on the
descriptive city of rheidt
all the variables
that we have up here are now listed below
copied into table 1 so make
sure that in the first row
the variable is after then
you will get exactly the same
variables down here that you copied up here
now we want to calculate the scatter parameters
for these variables say
we want the income  and the old
house will
now we have an overview here of the
values ​​we can have everything
displayed by default the
mean value minimum maximum and the
standard
deviation are selected here we can now click away the values ​​that
we do not want and can
click on the values ​​that we would like
to have for  example the standard
deviation the variance and the range
now we simply get a
table below with the radiation parameters
the standard deviation the variance the
range we can also have the panel
1 and could output two that
easily you can evaluate your data online with the delta chip
if  you stupid not g  anz
just google for peter tip on
datatec you will find great tutorials and
evaluate your data directly online in no time
if you want to be informed
as soon as a new video of mine
comes out just subscribe to this
channel and click on the bell thank you and see you
next time